good morning I'm delighted to join Dean
Miller in welcoming the class of 2015 to
Yale I want to welcome also the
relatives and friends who have
accompanied you here and especially your
parents as a father of four college
graduates I know how proud you you
parents are of your children's
achievement and how hopeful you are for
their future and how many concerns large
and small that you have at this moment
so let me try to reassure you your
children are going to love it here and I
expect that you're going to enjoy your
association with Yale as well whether
you are a returning graduate of one of
the or or whether you're one of the vast
majority of parents who never set foot
in new haven until your children started
to think about where to go to college
you may take comfort in learning that
surveys have shown that Yale parents are
the most satisfied in the Ivy League so
welcome to Yale family we're so pleased
to have your children with us and we'll
do our best to provide them with
abundant opportunities to learn and
thrive in the four years ahead and to
provide shelter from the storm in the
next 48 hours NTU class of 2015 I make
the same pledge for you these next four
years will be a time of opportunity
unlike any other here you are surrounded
by astonishing resources fascinating
fellow students from all over the world
a learning and caring faculty intimate
residential college communities a
magnificent library to extraordinary art
museums an outstanding Museum of Natural
History superb athletic facility
and student organizations covering every
conceivable interest of the Performing
Arts politics community service among
them you will have complete freedom to
explore to learn about new subjects to
meet new people and to pursue new
passions you will have chances to expand
your horizons to widen your scope of
vision to see the world from many
perspectives I want to encourage you in
every way that I can to make the most of
this rare and unique opportunity the
simple truth is we need you in these
times of great uncertainty when we seem
unable to deal with our gravest problems
we desperately need an infusion of
broadly educated citizens and leaders to
join the debates to raise the level of
discourse and to move us in the right
direction we know all too well the
missed opportunities of the past few
years we entered 2009 full of hope that
the world's nations could agree to save
the planet from the scourge of global
warming but the US Congress dead locked
in a struggle that was dominated by the
parochial interests of various
industries and regions and it failed to
act then in Copenhagen efforts to reach
a global agreement were foiled when
neither the United States nor the
developing nations were willing to
compromise for the good of all and only
the European nations saw the big picture
consider our current economic condition
since January 2009 it has been clear
that there's only one way to prevent a
deep and prolonged recession and avoid
persistent high unemployment I'm an
economist by the way we needed then as
we need now a massive fiscal stimulus in
the form of direct job creation not tax
cuts and we need it at the same time to
make a commitment to reduce the federal
budget deficit
dramatically over a period of years not
immediately since that would prolong the
recession but predictably we finally
faced the question of deficit reduction
this summer but ideological rigidity and
parochialism of members of Congress
moved the dialog away from the big
picture and paralyzed us with rigid
simplistic formulas no tax increases no
increase in the debt ceiling no cuts to
Social Security no cuts to Medicare
after weeks of deadlock we took only a
tiny step forward last December david
Leonhardt a member of the yale college
class of nineteen ninety-four identified
with crystal clarity the issues we face
in the form of a picture that he
published in the new york times i call
it a budget su doku in this brilliant
graphical display he demonstrated that
no combination of discretionary spending
cuts could close the federal budget gap
by 2020 the only way to do so involves
some combination of reducing social
security controlling Medicare and
Medicaid the costs of Medicare and
Medicaid reducing defense spending and
raising taxes or at least allowing the
Bush tax cuts to expire David sodoku
allowed his readers to see the big
picture very clearly and he was awarded
for this the Pulitzer Prize I'm going to
make the audacious claim that David's
Yale education had a lot to do with his
ability to see the big picture
he experienced just as you will over the
next four years exposure to a variety of
disciplines in his case mathematics
economics politics and history not to
mention our history this broad education
has allowed him to look beyond the
small-mindedness of what politicians say
to interpret the larger trends driving
the economy and society he also learned
to write clearly analytically and
forcefully he mastered this essential
tool not simply by taking English
courses but also through his principal
extracurricular activity as a reporter
for and subsequently editor of the Yale
Daily News david Leonhardt is one of
many visible examples of the profound
way in which the liberal arts education
that you are about to experience can
help you develop the capacity to see the
big picture by sampling courses across a
wide range of disciplines you will learn
to see problems from multiple
perspectives and by learning to think
critically and analytically you will
become dis inclined to accept simplified
slogans as truth you'll be more able to
see subtle interconnections and more
capable of forging solutions that
embrace complexity without being
overwhelmed by it no matter what
subjects you choose to pursue in depth
you will be required in your first two
years to develop some breath and you
will be challenged to think for
yourselves independently and
analytically in short you will equip
yourselves in the words of Yale
president Jeremiah day writing in 1828
with both the discipline and the
furniture of the mind rendering you
capable of distinguishing clear and
convincing arguments from doctrinaire
assertions and unexamined prejudices you
will learn how to see the forest for the
this capacity to see the big picture has
been a characteristic of Yale graduates
for decades in 1916 as America SAT by
watching a world war that many believed
it would inevitably enter a group of
yale college students came to realize
that the new technology of aviation
might potentially change the shape of
warfare while still in school they
convinced the navy to constitute them as
the first squadron of what became the
Naval Air Reserve in March 1917 these 29
young aviators left school on mass and
enlisted in the Navy immediately
comprising more than one-third of the
military's qualified pilots they made a
substantial contribution to the Allied
war effort because their Yale education
helped them to see clearly what others
could not aviation has a role in the
story of another Yale a Yale graduate
who was capable of seeing the big
picture Fred Smith classic 1966 had a
vision that came to revolutionize the
transportation of documents and small
parcels in the senior essay that he
submitted to the Yale Economics
Department he laid out a simple idea
that shipments might be gathered from
metropolitan areas all over the United
States and flown in the evening to one
central hub where they'd be reloaded
onto planes headed to their destination
areas and then flown out for delivery
the next day now the oft-repeated story
is that mr. Smith earned a C grade for
his efforts and then went on after
serving in the military to found a
logistics company we now know as Federal
Express according to the legend he saw
the big picture even if his economics
professor did not
alas it's not true that he got to see
but it does make the story better in the
telling lest you think that airplanes
always figure into the narratives of
Yale graduates capable of seeing the big
pictures let me give you two more
examples when Ruth to go Leah class of
2003 served as a summer intern in
Guatemala she came to recognize that
women in the rural villages in which she
was working made weavings of unusual
quality and beauty but they sold for
nearly nothing in local markets Ruth
encouraged these women to form
cooperatives and market their wares over
the Internet she brought them fashion
magazines to inspire them to weave
woolens in patterns that would appeal to
North American tastes today the earnings
of the cooperatives that Ruth helped to
establish provide substantial support
through public education as well as
access to electricity and clean water
and public health in more than 30
Guatemalan villages just one more david
levin no relation studied history and
the history of education at yale and he
designed and directed a tutoring program
for New Haven school children while he
was here he then joined Teach for
America and came to an understanding of
why k through 12 education was failing
in our inner-city schools in his big
picture the students needed the
discipline to focus on their work the
self-confidence to believe that they
could succeed and the motivation to
recognize that their discipline would be
rewarded with a better life if they
managed to graduate and attend college
from this inspiration came the Kipp
schools which David founded in
partnership with Michael Feinberg the
graduate of another Ivy League school
hip has been a pioneer in urban
education demonstrating a model that
truly works these stories inspire us
with the achievements of those who
started here just like you
with great potential curiosity
open-mindedness and a desire to make a
difference in the world the
extraordinary resources of Yale College
will give you an opportunity to realize
that potential to exercise that
curiosity to expand the mud that mind
beyond anything you can possibly now
imagine and to fulfill that desire to
make a difference if you stretch to your
limits take courses and engage in
extracurricular activities that broaden
and challenge you then you too will
develop the capacity to see the big
picture we're counting on you you're off
on a grand adventure make the most of it
welcome to you